quiet corridors
and unused lockers our children continue
to count the cost
of this pandemic this week ulster
grammar school in the west midlands
told a third of pupils over 300 in total
not to come in after a handful tested
positive
out of nowhere we suddenly have 12 cases
in a matter of days when we contact
trace those 12 cases have taken out over
300
of the remaining 900 students in school
and that fact is half
of those in years seven to ten those not
in the sixth form so a huge impact
came out of nowhere and there are a lot
of quite
um disgruntled and irate parents and
frustrated students
teachers say at least in lockdown they
could plan
online lessons in some ways this is more
disruptive
this empty classroom would normally be
hosting a year 9 biology lesson
but the teacher is self isolating as is
the whole year
of 155 students because of a mini
outbreak of seven cases
across england 375 000 children
are not in classrooms like this because
of covid19
and only a fraction of them actually
have the virus
parents who've been forced to isolate
their children are frustrated
my daughter's isolating at the moment
she's not happy with it
she's year 10 so she's quite concerned
about her
gcses and how what form they're going to
take
she's doing her lateral flow testing
twice a week so
we're confident she doesn't have
covered at the moment the government's
considering bringing in a new system
that it's been trailing in schools
such as west hawton high school in
bolton
rather than bubbling and sending whole
groups home if someone tests positive
instead schools will conduct a daily
testing regime
on those who've been in close contact
we've saved in that time over 350 what
would have been lost
days to isolation that's over 500
students and staff
who take part in in the in the clinical
trial that allows them to come into
school in the morning for their daily
lateral flow tests and twice in that
period of time a pcr test as well
receive their results negative in our
tent
and then go and take part in lessons as
normal the government says it will
decide in the next few weeks whether to
roll out this program for the autumn
term
we'll look at the results of the trial
and we'll make any decisions we'll be
announced before
we make a decision on step four going
forward but
you know we have to do everything we can
to minimize the risk of transmission
of this virus they are the least
vaccinated section of our population and
therefore the path
of least resistance for the virus but
as the wider population becomes ever
more protected by the vaccine
the argument grows that disruption to
school life
can't continue jason farrell sky news